hey everyone welcome to today's quiz on
microsoft azure
so we will be starting with the quiz
soon we will be waiting for more people
to join in
meanwhile uh let me give you a quick
overview of what is asher and why is it
so intrin these days
but before that let me tell you one very
interesting quiz aspect make sure to
hang around until the end of the quiz
for a chance to win amazing amazon
vouchers if you're among the top three
scorers on the quiz leaderboard
so let's just wait for two more minutes
and
we'll start
so let's start with the journey on this
quiz
so talking about azure the first
question that comes to mind is what it
is and how azure is so hyped up these
days
so well after aws microsoft azure claims
the second highest market share in the
us for cloud computing services
microsoft claims that approximately 1
000 businesses are moving to or using
microsoft azure for cloud computing
which means that an extra almost 3 lakh
65 000 businesses will require azure
specialists each year the fact that more
than 50 of fortune
500 organizations use azure as their
cloud platform demonstrates the gross
growing demand for azure specialists
so now talking about what is azure the
azure cloud platform is made up of more
than 200 products and cloud services
that can be used to develop new
solutions addresses
current products and problems and
foresee the future utilizing your
preferred tools and framework
you can create execute and manage apps
across various clouds on premises and at
the edge
now that we know what is azure let's
have a look at what all services azure
has to offer
now while azure contains over 100
services but the azure services you'll
use most frequently as a developer are
azure app services now your code simply
has to be deployed to azure all
infrastructure management tasks such as
loading balancing high availability and
auto scaling are handled by azure app
services
now azure static web apps
static web applications have azure
functions api integrations and create
and deploy themselves automatically in
response to code changes
next is azure functions
now azure functions is a serverless
compute platform for writing short
distinct chunks of code that a wide
range of various inputs can trigger
serverless api development and even
driven architecture
organization are examples of common uses
now talking about azure container
instances
azure container instances may handle any
situation that isolated containers can
handle without orchestration
then comes azure kubernetes services
deploy a kubernetes cluster that is
prepared for production quickly to the
cloud and transfer the administrative
burden to azure
now azure handles
all the code written here critical
functions like health monitoring and
maintenance
so only the agents nodes require
management and upkeep
then comes azure spring app
now azure spring apps offers ci cd
integration monitoring configuration
management service discovery and many
more
next comes azure virtual machines
now as your vms provide a flexible
scalable computing environment for both
linux and
windows virtual machine
so now that we have the basics of azure
pretty clear let's move towards the
benefits of azure
so first is trust your cloud
obtain security that is built from the
ground up supported by a team of
professionals and proactive compliance
that businesses governments and startups
trust
second is operate hybrid seamlessly now
they'll meet you where you are whether
on-premises in various clouds or at the
edge
utilize hybrid cloud services to
integrate and manage your environments
third is
build on your terms now build how you
want and deploy where you want with the
dedication to open source and support
for all languages and frameworks
and the fourth one is be future ready
now microsoft's ongoing innovation
supports your current development and
your long-term product goals
so now let's also have a peek at some of
the uses of azure
so when it comes to uses of azure the
most hyped one is
healthcare
now trusted cloud capabilities boost
patient engagement foster teamwork among
the health care staff and enhance
clinical informatics and operational
insights to produce better health
insights and outcomes
then we have government with microsoft
azure you can meet your citizens
requirements
develop more quickly and achieve top
notch security and compliance
then we have
manufacturing now modernizing into a
small factory with azure can accelerate
corporate transformation and
manufacturing while staying on top of
consumer demands and market trends
then we have use the cloud security and
speed to transform your business enhance
risk management prevent fraud and
provide differentiating consumer
experiences
now also with microsoft azure you can
create individualized experiences
streamline supply chains and reinvent
multi-chain retain
so this was all about microsoft azure we
can now
start on our quiz
so to take part in this quiz it is
highly recommended to use your mobile
phone to visit the website of
www.mentimeter.com and use the code
being shown on the screen now you can
also use a different tab on your browser
to take part in the quiz but our live
stream will broadcast the result as soon
as the participants give the answers so
it's beneficial to have both screens
visible simultaneously
so once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the questions
the quicker you answer the more points
you get so be sure to think fast and
check faster
so now before starting with the quiz we
will wait for one more minute for more
people to join and then we'll start with
our very first question
now let's get started with a quiz
here comes the first question
with service in azure is used to manage
resources in azure
the options are
application insight as your portal
log analytics as your resource manager
you just have 15 seconds to answer these
questions
i can see only three people who are
able to answer this correctly now just
let's have a look at the leaderboard
so puggy is the fastest replier with
922p
and followed by ribbit and not ronald so
let's move on to the next question
which of the following statements is
true about an azure subscription
option a
using azure does not require a
subscription
you can't have more than one
subscription
and azure subscription is a logical unit
of azure services and all of the above
only one person was able to answer this
correctly
so let's have a look at the leaderboard
if it changes
we can see more people have joined the
quiz and this time dragon knight who was
the only correct answerer was also the
fastest one has joined race
well talking about the azure
subscription so a logical collection of
azure services that are connected to an
azure account is known as a subscription
now multiple subscription may be present
in a single as your account as your
services charges are calculated as per
their subscription
i hope next
question brings more person to the quiz
which of the following is part of the
azure ai services
option one is
hdinsight
option b as your deb test labs as your c
option c as your machine learning
service and option d both a and b
so this time maximum people were able to
answer this correctly it's azure machine
learning services now let's have a look
at the leaderboard
we can see the rankings changing and
this time anusha was the fastest as well
as the
first replier
now talking about developers developers
may train and use machine learning
models with the assistance of microsoft
azure machine learning a set of services
and tools now microsoft offers these
programs and services via the public
cloud azure
so i can see new
names joanna and bg join our leaderboard
i hope
they score more and give a tough
competition
now let's move on to the next question
which of the following could grant or
deny access based on the originating ip
address
option a azure active directory option b
as your firewall
option c vpn gateway and option d both a
and b
you have only 15 seconds to answer this
correctly
again maximum people were able to answer
this correctly it's azure firewall
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
anusha maintaining the first possession
yet the fastest reply was kashish
and
i can see more people have joined uh
welcome you all i hope you do more well
and give a
tough competition to everyone
now
moving towards the next question
let me give you some insight about the
azure firewall now
your azure virtual network resources are
secured by the cloud-based network
security services which is azure
firewall now at a minimum a public
static ip address must be established
for azure firewall
this ip address or group of ip addresses
is used as the firewalls external
connection point
now moving on to the next question
azure vms and storage services fall
under which of the following cloud
computing models
infrastructure as a service
platform as a service or software as a
service or all of the above
again maximum people were able to answer
this correctly let's have a look at who
was the fastest supplier
kashish now has occupied the first
position as well as
the fastest replier
now
your depending on the company's needs
azure provides a vast area of
infrastructure as a service resources
such as container servers and virtual
machines which allow you to host
websites also backup your data develop
and test environments and much more now
these resource range from commune
are networking to security and storage
now moving on to the next question
azure storage plays the same role in
azure that plays in amazon web services
now the options are ec2
s3
or ec3
or all of the mentioned
you just have 15 seconds to answer this
correctly
again five people were able to answer
this correctly now let's have a look at
the leaderboard what it says
if the positions changes this time
cash is
still being the fastest and at the top
position
uh we can see new people have joined
hassan h of priyanka welcome you all
now let's move on to the next question
question 7.
auroral zone upwelling release
experiment is the full form of azure is
it true
or false
you just have 15 seconds to answer this
correctly
let's see how many people are able to
answer this
well only three people were able to
answer this correctly and maximum people
got it wrong yeah
this is a surprising thing but yes azure
has a full form aurora's own upwelling
release experiment with which was later
shortened in 2014 to microsoft azure
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
i think this question will change the
parameters a lot
this time we have new
top position holder which is sorbi and
azrik being the fastest replier
now let's
have a next question
what are the roles in microsoft azure
worker role vm role or web role or all
of these
you just have 15 seconds to answer this
correctly let's see how many people get
this
answer correctly
all of i think
except for one all of them got the
answer it's all of these
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
this time we have three fastest replier
kashish anusha and sai pranith kashish
still holds the first possession and
anusha isn't third i think
these people are gonna give give them
a tough competition this time
uh
now moving on to the next question
which azure management tool analyzes
resources and provide recommendations to
optimize deployments
as your advisor azure recommend azure
proactive or azure optimize
it quickly to be the fastest replier
okay i
can see that maximum people were not
able to answer this correctly only five
people answer this correctly
so as azure advisor examines resource
configurations and suggests how to
increase cloud deployments cost or
performance availability or talking
about the security it gives advice on
how to manage different resources such
as virtual machines availability
settings and app gateways
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
what is
the
parameters for dynamics this time if
this question changes anything
this time we have new fastest reply
which is pushkar but kashish still holds
the first position
now let's have a look at our next
question
which azure services helps enterprises
deploy and manage a hybrid cloud
architecture
as your stack as your outpost as your
pack
or azure
this time we have another fastest
replier which is viber though he
ranks a little bit low i
believe that he can
[Music]
speed up his performance and
kashish still holds the first position
i can see anusha has dropped down to
fourth position
moving on to the next question
we have
azure experienced a multi-day outage in
march 2022 that affected customers in
europe and the united kingdom
what caused the outage
it was human error capacity issues
severe weather or security breach
you have just 15 seconds to answer this
correctly
so six people were able to answer this
correctly
let's
have a look at the leaderboard
those six people were able to answer
this correctly it didn't bring much
change to the leaderboard caches is
still the fastest and also holds the
first position
now
as your
systems saw increased utilizations
during the pandemic due to the sudden
increase in remote work and reliance on
cloud-based online collaboration
services due to this clients in europe
and the uk could not launch their
virtual machines now according to the
even post modem
vm capacity limitations were the root
cause for the outage
6136 firms suffered delays throughout
the incidents according to azure
now let's have a look at our next
question
microsoft azure is the only cloud that
offers a service level agreement for its
api management service
is it true or false
i can see maximum people were not able
to answer this correctly only six people
were able to answer this
so
microsoft was the first cloud service
provider to offer an sla for its api
management services now it promises the
consumption basic standard and premium
tires of its api management service
instance
but later slas for their api management
tools have since been added by aws and
google as well
so let's have a look at the leaderboard
for this question
this time pushkar was the fastest
replier kashish still at the top
i would really like to see more names
competing with kashish for the top
position
guys remember there's a amazon voucher
as a
prize to the top three winners
let's back
up
coming to the next question
which company did microsoft acquire to
help customers plan and execute
migrations to azure
there's it was optionally cyber x option
b cloudify option c
cloudant or option d
mover
wow only two people who answer were able
to answer this correctly it's mover
now in september 2019 microsoft
purchased the data migration startup
mover
mover tools continuously monitor and
evaluate id resources to assist with
planning and facilitating migrations
based on the id infrastructure and
resource usage mover technology
automates discovery provides an
assessment and suggests migration
alternatives
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
if it changes the dynamics
if we are able to see new names to the
leaderboard this time
this time sai pranith was the first
replier and kashish is still at the top
now coming to the next question
which of the following azure cloud
services offers serverless capabilities
azure functions as your app service
as your kubernetes service or aks
or all of the above
we have just discussed about azure
services let's see
who or listen to it very carefully
well i can see maximum people were able
to answer this correctly
let's have a look at the leaderboard
now developers can leverage various
azure services to create and maintain
apps without worrying about managing
infrastructure the service computing
option on the platform called azure
functions and that runs the code in
reaction to events
this time as rick was the fastest
replier
yet i can see gashes still holds the top
position
moving on to the next question
azure cognitive services is made up of
which five service components
these are the options you have just 15
seconds to answer them correctly
let's see who all are able to manage
this question answer this question
correctly this time
well six people were able to answer this
correctly
now
microsoft machine learning and ai
portfolio include azure cognitive
services it consists of services
software development kits and apis that
aid in the creation of intelligent
applications by developers so the vision
speech language search and developers
use decision apis to incorporate
cognitive elements into their apps such
as facial recognition speaker
recognition and language translation
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
well this time our fastest reply was
hassan and kashish is still holding the
first position come on people nobody is
fighting for the first position this
time
now coming to the next question
azure service fabric is a distributed
systems platform aimed primarily at
containers and
microservices serverless architectures
blockchain projects or all of the above
time's up
wow maximum people were not able to get
this answer correctly it's option a
containers and micro services
now an organization may create or deploy
or manage containers and microservices
with the aid of azure service fabric it
is frequently employed for distributed
applications
that demand scalability and
dependability
numerous services such as azure cosmo db
and azure event hubs are powered by it
the service supports clusters and azure
and also on premises
let's see if this question
brings any change to the dynamics or to
the first position that is already held
by kashish
wow okay only two people were able to
answer this question correctly this time
from the top ten wiper was the fastest
one but still kashish holds the first
position
moving on to the next question
which microsoft azure cloud security
tool
can enterprise use for key management
azure guard duty as your lockdown as
your key management or as your key vault
let's see how many people get this
answer correctly and
you have only 15 seconds to answer this
correctly
again maximum people were able to answer
this
it's azure keyword now enterprises can
generate and maintain encryption keys
using
azure keyword tokens passwords and api
keys are just a few objects or
administrators can keep and manage
access to additionally azure keyword
centrally stores application secrets
giving users more control over
distribution and
access now let's
have a quick look at the leaderboard
this time i can see new names have
joined a leaderboard ajo puja welcome
i hope you'll speed up your performance
and
fight for the first position as kashish
is still holding it
let's see if anybody else can
compete with him in the next question
now moving on to the next question
azure blob storage offers how many
storage
tiers
three
four
five
or eight
seven people were able to answer this
correctly now azure blog offers four
storage levels the platform's object
storage service premium hot cool and
archive
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
i can see pushkar has joined the race
and he was also the fastest replier
now let's move on to the next question
what are special azure regions
this can be a tricky one
first is u.s government virginia and u.s
government
iowa
second option is china east and china
north
third option is germany central and
germany northeast and fourth is all of
these
wow okay 11 people were able to answer
this correctly
this was quite unexpected
let's have a look at the leaderboard
this time the fastest reply was azerik
and we have
new
joining to our leaderboard which is
shweta
now i can see serbi has also
buckled up and
is at the second position
let's have a look at the
next question
come on people we are halfway through
the quiz kashish is still holding the
first position
let's see how many are people how many
are of you are going to fight for it
now do scale sets work with azure
availability sets
no
yes or not sure
you just have 15 seconds to answer this
question
11 people were able to answer this
correctly
now you can construct the scale set
across availability zones to shield your
virtual machine
from data center level failures each of
the minimum three distinct zones in an
azure region
with support for availability zones has
its own independent power source network
and cooling
now let's have a quick look at the
leaderboard
okay this time puja was our fastest
replier welcome puja and
i can see serbia and sai panit is
competing with each other for the second
and third position
what about the rest of the people
now coming to the next question
which service in azure is used to manage
resources in azure
application insight azure portal
log analytics or your resource manager
you just have 15 seconds to answer this
question
11 people were able to answer this
correctly
now management service is referred to as
a config element
the virtual machines are to blame for
this it solely utilizes the services and
programs that are deployed
let's have a look at the leaderboard
this time if it
brings any changes to the dynamics of
leaderboard
this time sorry was the fastest one and
she's
holding the third position
kashish is still at the first
coming to the question number 22
which service in azure is used to manage
resources in azure
application insight azure portal log
analytics and azure resource manager
let's have a look at the leaderboard
this time we have two fastest replier
which is cypranim and anusha
coming to the next question
well did you guys know that availability
zones defend your virtual machine scale
sets
and in
before asha was named as your
as microsoft azure it was
first named as project red dog
now moving on to the next question scale
sets work with azure availability sets
true or false
you have 15 seconds to answer this
question
16 people were able to answer this
correctly it's true you can construct a
scale set across availability zones to
shield your virtual machines
let's have a look at the leaderboard
this time kashish was the fastest also
holds the first position
coming to the next question
azure was launched in which year
it's 2010
2011
2012 or
2009.
you have 15 seconds to answer this
question correctly
i can see only four people were able to
answer this correctly
let's have a look at the leaderboard
only two people from the leaderboard
were able to answer this correctly
vishal was the fastest supplier kashish
still holds the first position and
surubi moves to the second one
now like i said with the internal
project code name project red dock azure
was first unveiled at microsoft
professional developers conference pdc
in october 2008. now it was initially
released in february 2010 as windows
azure and changed its name
to microsoft azure on march 25th 2014.
moving on to the next question
a role is a virtual machine instance
running a microsoft iis web server that
can accept and respond to http or http's
request
options are
worker
server
web or client
only seven people were able to answer
this correctly i can see rest
were more focusing on servo
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
i can see a new name in us in the
leaderboard which is hassan he was also
the fastest replier
now coming to the question number 30
which is the last question let's see if
this question
acts as a charm for any of the people to
get to the first position
runtime polymorphism is achieved by
operator overloading virtual function
friend function
or all of the above
let's see how many people get this
correctly
okay this time maximum people were able
to get this correctly it's all of the
abba
now runtime polymorphism is a process in
which a call to an overridden method is
resolved at runtime rather than compile
time
now let's have a look at the lead board
okay people kashish has
still managed to remain at the top and
uh
our top
performers are should be pushkar and
kashish
thank you people i hope you enjoyed this
quiz and learn something new from it